welcome to Bucharest everybody to the  2019 Superbad rapid and blitz healthier  at stationary country club  it's a beautiful playing hall a  beautiful setting we have a lot of  celebrities here Boris Becker is in the  house Fabiano Caruana and a lot of a lot  of strong chess players let's go and get  the drawing of the last red  [Music]  thank you for all of your brand chat  Samantha and I wish your own over though  for sure  just one we have but I suppose all of us  will be we have to have the community on  the beach and to enjoy  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  we had an amazing opening ceremony the  drawing of the lots was made everybody  had a lot of fun the organizer put on a  show for us  now we're ready to go back to the action